the girag an experience of renamed to
rest his work did you ever pay attention
no she was on my podcast since she
detailed what the IRA did the internet
research right in Russia and it was
really fascinating they had set up like
a fake black lives matter account and
and then they would talk about how as
black Americans we can't vote for
Hillary Clinton because of this and they
started they developed these communities
these write a really large online pages
where there was on Facebook or Instagram
or whatever it was where they spoke as
like a southern separatist or as a
Muslim yeah I mean that dozens of and
they developed these communities and
they would set up these organizations
and then they would have events where
they had one where they had a texas
secession event directly across the
street from a muslim pride event and
they did it on purpose so that they
would fight they put him across the
street from each other they organized
these Facebook pages in these events and
these people show up these people that
are texas is said we should leave the
union you know we can Texas is a
republic and then they have these other
people on one they want like Muslim
rights and they want the Sharia law and
they put them right next to each other
yeah they're there they're literally
engineering argument and their
engineering fighting and the idea was
that someone wanted this to this idea of
promoting discord right they wanted
arguments they wanted to [ __ ] with our
democracy and then they could shift it
just a little bit by doing this by
having these arguments by pretending
that they're there for lbgtq rights but
they're really not but they're really
just some Russians are just you know
talking [ __ ] and that this is what we
need to do we need to radicalize they
had an Tifa groups at all right
write-ups I mean Israel and Saudi Arabia
do the same thing except we right now
it's fascinating that we just focusing
on Russia when my god this is happening
on every front I mean look at going back
to Pete Buddha judge you say his name
but he has like hundreds of sock puppet
accounts that are all like propping each
other up on there oh my god I just saw
it's like
Black's for Pete Buddha Jays for puja
it's like all these making these his I
mean I guess he thought that that was I
don't know injected with corporate money
that he's just like all right make a
hundred sock puppet accounts it's like
everyone does this [ __ ] but when we
focus and on just Russia and then of
course you have the removal of you know
Syrian accounts you have the removal of
Pro Maduro accounts on Twitter why is it
only that we're talking about our
so-called enemies that these are the
people who are sowing discord in
fomenting radical discontent what about
all the other countries that you know we
do it all over the world what about all
the other countries that are doing the
same thing so if he really does have
these sock puppet accounts that are
doing this that are pretending that
these are just fans you know that's
that's some sleazy [ __ ] yeah it's easy
as that I mean that's as sleazy as it
gets in my opinion that's a dirty [ __ ]
you're pretending you're a person who's
just an independent person who's
supporting you and really just is an
employee who's their first stop again
right and especially like the identity
politics thing like all of the different
groups you know marginalized groups
support you yeah it's all fake well the
crazy reserve you saw that Town Hall
after the shooting a Kyle my guy and
there everyone saying how the [ __ ] are
you gonna run for president right I
can't even run a city right yeah
does he have a job this I'm confused you
never like have jobs right you're
running for president giant who's
running the city what's going on yeah
imagine right if I just said hey during
this I can do this podcast anymore I'm
gonna go get a Brian Cowen he's gonna be
media now on experience like I think
what people don't [ __ ] is happening like
Bill DeBlasio it's like you have a
[ __ ] city to run yeah why are you
running for president how can you the
[ __ ] metros find a part do much time
do you spend actually being married yes
[ __ ] yeah money back dude they just want
the book deals they want to go on the
view they want a reason to be relevant
for you it's disgusting it's pretty
gross it should be illegal Meghan McCain
it really should be if you really should
you should quit your [ __ ] job
whatever you have and dedicate 100% of
your time to doing that yeah if you
think that you could have that
but first of all everyone knows what a
grueling thing it is to run for
president it is a [ __ ] time consuming
right massive commitment to your energy
yeah how can you do that and also be the
mayor of South Bend yeah yeah you just
have to be on the phone begging for
donations when you're not you know
jumping on tables like Robert O'Rourke
is all over the country it's a lot of
work
yeah there's no way you run in that city
right I don't [ __ ] crazy of these
people's egos I mean they say that Trump
is this existential threat that he's the
next Hitler he's mentally incapacitated
yet they all jump in the race because
they think they're the smartest people
in the world so it's like Bill DeBlasio
it's like really yeah they're pulling
solo drop out dude this is all to try to
prevent Bernie from winning does it
really is
[Applause]